I came to the whole MacGyver thing kind of late. I never saw the TV show. In fact, I heard of MacGyver because he kept showing up in rap lyrics.
我对“马盖先”（MacGyver）这一套东西接触得比较晚。我从没看过这部电视剧。事实上，我听说马盖先是因为他不断出现在说唱歌曲的歌词里。
MacGyver, of course, is the guy who fought bad guys, but never used a gun. He used his scientific knowledge. He used sheer inventiveness to get himself out of scrapes. The show's been off the air for years, but he still shows up in dozens of songs.
马盖先，当然，就是那个对抗坏人却从不用枪的家伙。他利用自己的科学知识，利用纯粹的创造力来让自己摆脱困境。这部剧已经停播多年了，但他仍然出现在几十首歌里。
[MUSIC - SAMPLES OF MACGYVER REFERENCES IN HIP HOP SONGS]
[音乐 - 嘻哈歌曲中马盖先的引用片段]
MacGyver would turn a hot water bottle into a tear gas dispenser, or roll up a map to turn it into an impromptu dart gun, or mix an antidote to poison from common ingredients found at his local shopping mall, or escape from evildoers using only a bobby pin or piece of gum, notoriously, or the wrapper from the gum, in some diabolically clever way.
马盖先会把热水袋变成催泪瓦斯喷射器，或者把地图卷起来变成即兴飞镖枪，或者用当地购物中心能找到的常见材料混合出毒药的解药，或者利用发夹、口香糖，甚至像大家所熟知的那样，用口香糖包装纸以某种极其巧妙的方式从坏人手中逃脱。
In real life, most of us never get to be that clever. In real life, even when there's a situation like, for instance, the largest power outage in US history, it's the professionals who have to jury rig new wiring routes, to figure out how to keep hospitals and emergency services going. It's the professionals who have to be brilliantly ingenious.
在现实生活中，我们大多数人永远无法那么聪明。在现实生活中，即使出现像美国历史上最大规模停电这样的情况，也必须由专业人员来临时拼凑新的线路，想方设法维持医院和紧急服务的运转。必须有极其聪明的专业人员才能解决问题。
Let's see, ingenuity. I am chewing gum right now just in case I might need to use it on something.
让我想想，独创性。我现在正嚼着口香糖，以防万一我可能需要用它来解决什么问题。
When I reached our contributing editor, Sarah Vowell, in blacked-out New York this Thursday night, she was reading by candlelight. She'd managed to boil water on a gas stove. But that was about all the MacGyver-like ingenuity her situation seemed to call for.
这个周四晚上，当我在电力中断的纽约联系上我们的特约编辑萨拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）时，她正点着蜡烛读书。她设法在煤气灶上烧开了水。但这就是她的处境所需要的全部马盖先式的独创性了。
Yeah. I mean, I have the gum, and I have the situation. And so far, everything's fine.
是啊。我的意思是，我有口香糖，也有这种情况。到目前为止，一切都很好。
Well, no, let's just think for a second. There must be something you can do with that gum.
嗯，不，咱们想一想。你肯定能用那块口香糖做点什么。
Um-- well, I guess if there was some kind of windstorm, I could latch one of the candles down with it, you know? I'm trying to wrench any little ounce of drama out of this for you that I can, but--
嗯——好吧，我想如果有什么大风，我可以用它把蜡烛固定住，你知道吗？我正试着为你从这件事里挤出哪怕一点点戏剧性，但是——
But there is no drama.
但这里根本没有戏剧性。
I wish I could tell you something, and then you could put that Mission: Impossible music underneath me, and it would sound really super exciting, but--
我真希望能告诉你点什么，然后你就可以在我背景里放那段《碟中谍》的音乐，听起来会非常刺激，但是——
No, look. Hold on. I'll put that music under you right now.
不，看，等一下。我现在就给你配上那段音乐。
I am going to take a bath, and light a candle! Yeah, and then I might go to bed early. I bet that line sounds really good with the Mission: Impossible music underneath. I might even take a Benadryl!
我要去洗个澡，点支蜡烛！是的，然后我可能会早点睡觉。我敢打赌，那句话配上《碟中谍》的音乐听起来一定很棒。我甚至可能会吃一片苯海拉明！
Ingenious problem solving adventures. We almost never get them in our daily lives. And so today on our radio program we have searched, and we have found not one, not two, not three, but four real-life situations, real-life MacGyver solutions. Cases cracked by ordinary people like you and me.
充满独创性的冒险。我们的日常生活中几乎从未有过这种时刻。所以今天在我们的广播节目中，我们搜寻并发现了——不是一个，不是两个，不是三个，而是四个——真实的马盖先式解决方案。由像你我这样的普通人解决的案例。
You know, this is completely the wrong music. Just hold on for a second.
你知道，这音乐完全放错了。等一下。
[MUSIC - THEME FROM "MACGYVER"]
[音乐 - 《马盖先》主题曲]
There we go. The MacGyver theme.
这就对了。马盖先的主题曲。
One story takes place in prison. One involves a very low-budget movie. One solves a problem that most of us have had at one time or another in love. And one, our first act, is the true story of a potential personal crisis averted in an instant.
一个故事发生在监狱里。一个涉及一部成本极低的电影。一个解决了我们大多数人在爱情中都曾遇到过的问题。还有一个，我们第一幕的故事，是一个潜在的个人危机瞬间化解的真实故事。
It is This American Life from Public Radio International and WBEZ Chicago. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是来自国际公共广播电台和芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One. Bolt of Lightning, Pro and Con.
第一幕。闪电一击，利弊得失。
When Chuck Klosterman was 20 years old, a junior at the University of North Dakota, when he had his very first girlfriend, she was 29. An adult. He was very young. And Valentine's Day arrived. The day that he came up with a MacGyver-like solution, in an instant, in a flash. Here was the situation.
查克·克洛斯特曼（Chuck Klosterman）20岁时，是北达科他大学的大三学生，那时他有了第一个女朋友，她29岁。是个成年人。他当时非常年轻。情人节到了。在那一瞬间，在那一闪念间，他想出了一个类似马盖先的解决方案。情况是这样的。
Somehow I was not aware that adults gave presents at Valentine's Day. Like, I only thought children did that, they gave cards to each other, you know?
不知怎么的，我不知道成年人在情人节会送礼物。就像，我只以为那是小孩子做的事，他们给彼此送贺卡，你知道吗？
Right.  At elementary school, there's swapping cards.
对。在小学，大家会交换贺卡。
Yeah. It didn't seem possible to me that adult people gave presents at Valentine's Day. I'm not sure how I managed to get to be 20 and be unaware of this, but that was sort of the situation.
是的。我觉得成年人在情人节送礼物是不可能的。我不知道我是怎么活到20岁还不知道这一点的，但这大概就是当时的情况。
And we went to the movie Groundhog Day on Valentine's Day. And I was still living in a dormitory. So we went back to my dorm room, OK? And we're hanging out there, and all of a sudden, she gives me all these presents. She gives me, like, a Soul Asylum album, and a copy of the book Go, Dog. Go!, which I must have mentioned was my favorite book when I was five or something. There were all these sort of really kind of thoughtful gifts, and a whole bunch of them. And she'd obviously put a great deal of effort into the thought behind giving me these things.
情人节那天我们去看了电影《土拨鼠之日》。我当时还住在宿舍里。所以我们回到我的宿舍房间，好吗？我们在那儿闲逛，突然，她给了我好多礼物。她给了我一张Soul Asylum乐队的专辑，还有一本《Go, Dog. Go!》，我一定是在五岁的时候说过那是我的最爱之类的。这些礼物都非常贴心，而且有好几件。很明显，她在送我这些东西的构思上花了很多心思。
And is your feeling of the noose sort of slowly tightening around your neck rising with each present?
随着每多出一件礼物，你那种被绞索勒住脖子的感觉是否在一点点加强？
Yeah. I'm sort of kind of paralyzed by fear now, because I realize that she has an expectation that I am going to reciprocate this somehow. And I guess I just didn't feel comfortable saying I didn't know that you were supposed to do this.
是的。我当时因为恐惧而几乎瘫痪了，因为我意识到她期待我也能以某种方式回馈这些礼物。我想我只是不好意思说我不知道情人节应该送礼物。
So I tried to remain as cool as possible, and I started walking toward my closet. OK? And as I was walking toward my closet, I kept kind of stalling for time, saying things like, you know, I really didn't know what to get. I didn't want to buy a gift that everybody would buy. I wanted to get you something very creative. I want it to be a reflection of our relationship. I'm just sort of coming up with all these different ways to sort of describe how not only do I have, like, a really wonderful gift-- something really cool-- but it's going to be metaphorical for basically our entire relationship.
所以我尽量保持冷静，开始向衣柜走去。好吗？当我走向衣柜时，我一直在拖延时间，说着诸如“我真的不知道该送什么，我不想买那种谁都会买的礼物，我想给你一些非常有创意的东西，我想让它成为我们关系的反映”之类的话。我只是在想各种各样的办法来描述我不仅有一个非常棒的礼物——一些非常酷的东西——而且它基本上是我们整个关系的隐喻。
But there's nothing in the closet. I have nothing in there. It's just my clothes. I don't know what I'd like-- and I don't really know what I'm doing now. Because I'm walking toward it, and I'm kind of slowly playing with the handle of the closet, and I'm just giving every indication that something is in there. But there's nothing in there. So I thought, maybe something will evolve in my closet. My shoes will become like a microwave or something, you know?
但衣柜里什么都没有。我里面什么都没有。只有我的衣服。我不知道我想要什么——而且我现在真的不知道自己在做什么。因为我走向衣柜，慢慢地摆弄着把手，给了她一种里面有东西的暗示。但里面什么都没有。所以我想，也许我的衣柜里会演化出什么来。我的鞋子会变成微波炉之类的，你知道吗？
But I begin opening this closet, and I look inside it. Of course to see nothing. Remember, nothing is in here. But I just see all my clothes lined up. And what I see is my high school football jacket. OK? And this is not like a letterman's jacket. This is just like a windbreaker-- you know, my name, Chuck, over the heart would be, like where the heart of the jacket is, with my number 18 underneath it. You know? I see this, right? And this thought just suddenly dawned on me, really quickly.
但我开始打开衣柜，往里面看。当然什么都没看到。记住，里面什么都没有。但我只看到我的衣服挂得整整齐齐。我看到的是我的高中足球队夹克。好吗？这不是那种字母夹克。这只是件防风衣——你知道，胸口位置应该有我的名字“查克”，下面是我的号码18。你知道吗？我看到了这个，对吧？这个念头突然闪过我的脑海，非常快。
So I turn to this woman and I say, well, here's the deal. You know, I never had a girlfriend all through high school, and I used to be very envious of all my friends who would give their football jackets to their girlfriends. And I kind of created this whole sort of narrative about how this had been a huge struggle through high school of not being able to give my football jackets to anyone. Which in truth, I never struggled with. I always thought those guys were idiots.
所以我转过身对那个女人说，好吧，是这样的。你知道，我整个高中都没有女朋友，我一直很羡慕那些把足球队夹克送给女朋友的朋友们。我编造了一个关于这在高中时一直是个巨大的挣扎的故事，说我无法把足球夹克送给任何人。事实上，我从来没挣扎过。我一直觉得那些家伙是白痴。
So then I said, I think it would be really awesome if you would accept this high school football jacket of mine. And she started crying. And she just loved this jacket. I mean, she seemed to think it was really nice, and really sweet, and generally very much unlike me.
于是我说，我想如果你能接受我这件高中足球队夹克，那就太棒了。她开始哭了。她简直太喜欢这件夹克了。我的意思是，她似乎觉得它非常好，非常甜蜜，而且总体上非常不像我的风格。
Afterwards, what would you feel when you would see her in the jacket? Would you feel good, or would you feel--
事后，当你看到她穿着那件夹克时，你会有什么感觉？你会感觉良好，还是会——
No, no. I felt-- not really.
不，不。我感觉——不太好。
Every single time she wore it.
每一次她穿它的时候。
Yeah. And she wore it all the time. And I always thought to myself, she really, really likes this jacket. She must really, really like the experience of getting it, and therefore, she must really, really like me. And yet, I couldn't really look at that jacket without being reminded that this is based on a complete fabrication.
是的。她经常穿它。我总是对自己说，她真的、真的非常喜欢这件夹克。她一定真的非常享受收到它的那一刻，因此，她一定真的非常喜欢我。然而，我无法看着那件夹克而不被提醒：这一切都建立在一个彻头彻尾的谎言之上。
Because I really view this as the most diabolical thing I've ever done, mostly because the end result was somebody being happy about it. Like, I would almost have less guilt over something terrible I did that caused someone to feel terrible. I'm mostly bothered by the fact that I did this terrible thing, and it made someone happy.
因为我真的认为这是我做过的最恶魔般的事情，主要是因为最终结果是有人因此感到快乐。就像，如果我做了一件可怕的事情导致某人感到痛苦，我反而不会有这么深的负罪感。让我困扰的是，我做了这件糟糕的事，它却让某人感到快乐。
In my mind, it would be so much better if this relationship had ended with her cheating on me or something. I would feel so much better about it if she had, at any point in our relationship, did anything negative to me. But she never did.
在我看来，如果这段关系以她背叛我之类的结局告终会好得多。如果她在我们关系的任何时候对我做过负面的事情，我会感觉好受得多。但她从来没有。
Well, you don't know. Maybe she's got a story like this too. Maybe she's-- [? when you told ?] her-- she could be, oh yeah, well, really? Well, there's this is one thing I've ever told you.
嗯，你不知道。也许她也有这样的故事。也许她——[？当你告诉？]她时——她可能会说，哦，真的吗？嗯，那这是我从未告诉过你的事。
Oh, man, I hope so. Man, I hope that she cheated on me with 10 guys. I would feel so much better about this. Like, while wearing the jacket, you know?
哦，天哪，我希望如此。天哪，我希望她背叛了我，找了十个男人。那样我会感觉好受得多。就像，在穿着那件夹克的时候，你知道吗？
Chuck Klosterman is the amazing writer behind Fargo Rock City and, more recently, Sex, Drugs, and Cocoa Puffs: A Low Culture Manifesto.
查克·克洛斯特曼是《法戈摇滚之城》以及最近的《性、毒品和可可粉：一部低俗文化宣言》背后的惊人作家。
Act Two. Files in Cakes, Ha!
第二幕。蛋糕里的锉刀，哈！
OK. Here's a situation where resources are scarce and people have to be inventive with what they have-- prison. There's this incredible book of prisoners' inventions called, straightforwardly enough, Prisoners' Inventions, by a California inmate who goes by the pseudonym Angelo. In the book, there are descriptions of the inventions that he and his cellmates, or cellies, have made, and these intricate, schematic drawings of devices to make cottage cheese and yogurt, tattoo guns, wake-up alarms, dice-- all of these items considered contraband, subject to confiscation by authorities.
好的。这是一个资源匮乏、人们必须利用现有条件发挥创造力的情况——监狱。有一本令人难以置信的囚犯发明书，书名就叫《囚犯发明》（Prisoners' Inventions），作者是一位化名为安杰洛（Angelo）的加州囚犯。书中描述了他和他的狱友们制作的发明，还有详细的设备草图，用来制作白干酪、酸奶、纹身枪、叫醒闹钟、骰子——所有这些物品都被视为违禁品，随时可能被当局没收。
An actor, Felix Solis, reads some excerpts.
演员费利克斯·索利斯（Felix Solis）朗读了其中的一些节选。
Modesty curtain. Because of the close quarters, modesty is one of the first casualties of prison life. My cellie, R, however, created this modesty curtain for when we use the toilet. It's just a simple amenity, a reminder, if you will, that some privacy and dignity is still possible.
谦虚帘。由于空间狭窄，隐私是监狱生活中最早丧失的东西之一。然而，我的狱友R为我们上厕所时创造了这个谦虚帘。这只是一项简单的便利设施，如果你愿意的话，它提醒着人们，某种隐私和尊严依然是可能的。
The curtain is a half sheet suspended from a tightly strung, triple-woven line. The sliding hangers are strings of paperclips attached to the sheet through small holes. The wall mounts are made from wooden dominoes and paperclips, and fastened to the wall with contact cement.
帘子是一半床单，悬挂在一条拉得紧紧的三重编织线上。滑动挂钩是用回形针串成，通过小孔挂在床单上。墙壁支架由木质多米诺骨牌和回形针制成，用强力胶固定在墙上。
Although the cops are notorious for confiscating inmate creations and many saw this curtain, none ever touched it, though a few ordered it taken down over the years. We never did take it down, and they never pursued the issue.
尽管警察以没收囚犯的创造物而闻名，很多人也看到了这道帘子，但没人动过它，尽管多年来有人下令把它拆掉。我们从来没有拆过，他们也从未追究过这个问题。
Ironically, it was a wimpy cellie that I eventually had who finally took it down, supposedly because of cops' warnings to do so. I think the truth of the matter was that he wanted all the paperclips for his own knick knack project.
讽刺的是，最终是后来分来的一个胆小的狱友把它拆了，据说是为了响应警察的警告。我认为真相是，他想把所有的回形针拿去弄他自己的小玩意儿。
Wall socket cigarette lighter. I would estimate that a good 60% of inmates smoke. Because of national anti-smoking campaigns, a major problem for smokers in prison has been the elimination of matches and cigarette lighters to discourage in-cell smoking. Variations of materials and methods are possible, but usually, a paperclip and a piece of pencil lead are inserted into the slits in one of the cell's wall sockets.
插座香烟点火器。据我估计，大约60%的囚犯抽烟。由于全国范围内的反吸烟运动，监狱里吸烟者面临的一个主要问题是消除火柴和打火机，以劝阻室内吸烟。虽然材料和方法各异，但通常是将回形针和一截铅笔芯插入牢房墙壁插座的缝隙中。
To achieve a light, a second piece of pencil graphite is used to make a quick bridge between the two terminals, forming a short circuit. At the same time, a piece of combustible material, like a toilet paper wick with fluffed up ends, is also brought close, and hopefully will catch fire from the momentary explosion of fire and heat. And there you have a light for your cigarette.
为了点火，用另一截铅笔石墨在两个端子之间快速搭接，形成短路。与此同时，一小块可燃材料（比如末端弄松的卫生纸引线）被靠近，希望通过瞬间的火花和热量将其点燃。这样你就给香烟点着了火。
Caution. When inserting the paperclip or pencil lead into the wall socket, don't accidentally ground yourself by brushing against the cell's stainless steel toilet or sink.
注意。将回形针或铅笔芯插入插座时，千万不要因为碰到牢房的不锈钢马桶或水槽而意外接地。
Toilet paper mache cup. We usually get a small packet of state Kool-Aid in our lunches each day. I like to save up the packets so that I can occasionally indulge in a large cup instead of just a small one every day.
卫生纸浆杯。我们每天的午餐通常会发一小袋政府供应的酷爱饮料粉。我喜欢把这些小袋攒起来，这样偶尔可以喝上一大杯，而不是每天只喝一小口。
This led to a problem the first time I found myself in administrative segregation, since for security reasons, only small paper coffee cups were issued for use there. Besides being too small, these cups tended to start leaking at the seams by about the fourth day of use. And with prison being the way it is, new cups could be obtained only once a week on a one-for-one basis. To get another, you have to turn in the old one.
这导致了第一次我在行政隔离区时出现了一个问题，因为出于安全考虑，那里只发小纸咖啡杯。这些杯子不仅太小，而且到了第四天左右，接缝处往往就开始漏水。鉴于监狱的情况，新杯子每周只能按“以旧换新”的原则领取一次。要拿一个新的，必须交回旧的。
Well, after stewing on this problem for a while, I came up with what I perceived as a crackpot solution, which after long hesitation, I decided to try out. To my surprise, it worked well, though it was a bitch to make, plus it used up a lot of toilet paper.
嗯，在这个问题上纠结了一段时间后，我想出了一个我自认为异想天开的解决方案，经过长时间的犹豫，我决定尝试一下。令我惊讶的是，它效果很好，尽管制作起来非常费劲，而且用掉了大量的卫生纸。
Using wet toilet paper, I formed a large paper mache cup around the fist of one hand. A really awkward piece of work, and very thick. Then I took the largest piece of Saran wrap that our lunch bread came in and inserted it inside the cup, leaving the excess sticking over the edge. Note that to prevent leakage, the plastic inside must be an unbroken sheet, so the result is a mess to look at, with lots of folds and wrinkles. And after allowing the whole thing to dry and harden for a few hours, it was ready for use.
我用湿卫生纸，在一只手的手拳上塑造了一个大纸浆杯。那是一件非常笨拙的作品，而且非常厚。然后我拿了一张午餐面包包装里最大的保鲜膜，把它放进杯子里，让多余的部分留在边缘外面。注意，为了防止渗漏，里面的塑料必须是一张完整的片材，所以成品看起来一团糟，有很多折痕和皱纹。让整个东西晾干硬化几个小时后，它就可以使用了。
To thwart possible confiscation, I put a large black dot on the bottom of the cup the size of the toilet paper roll core, and took to keeping the disguised cup in the new recessed toilet paper holder on the sink. A deception that worked so well that for all I know, the cup could still be in that cell, as I accidentally left it behind when I moved on.
为了防备被没收，我在杯子底部画了一个和卫生纸卷芯一样大的黑点，并将伪装好的杯子放在水槽边新的凹进式卫生纸架上。这个诡计非常成功，以至于据我所知，那个杯子可能还在那个牢房里，因为我搬走时意外把它留下了。
Excerpts from the book Prisoners' Inventions by a prisoner who goes by the name Angelo. It was read for us by Felix Solis, produced with the help of Jonathan Menjivar. Copies available at the whitewalls.org.
以上节选自化名为安杰洛的囚犯所著的《囚犯发明》一书。由费利克斯·索利斯为我们朗读，乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）协助制作。副本可在whitewalls.org获取。
Act Three. This is one of those schemes that falls into the category, sure, it sounds crazy, but it might just be crazy enough to work. It all begins simply enough. A man dreams of making a movie. He comes to Boston to film it. It's 1988. His name-- David Rudder.
第三幕。这是一个归类为“当然，听起来很疯狂，但它可能疯狂到足以奏效”的计划。一切开始得很简单。一个男人梦想着拍一部电影。他来到波士顿拍摄。那是1988年。他的名字——大卫·拉德（David Rudder）。
We couldn't get him to come on the radio, but we did get Elizabeth Gilbert, who wrote about what happened in GQ magazine.
我们无法请他来电台，但我们请到了伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特（Elizabeth Gilbert），她在《GQ》杂志上写下了发生的事情。
David Rudder is a first-time filmmaker. He's a producer from a place called Rudder Productions, David Rudder Movie Productions. And he's doing a very low-budget, a $1.3 million movie called The Knockdown, which is a romantic comedy about a historic preservationist trying to save an endangered building with the help of a buxom young architect. So he is going to be shooting this movie in Boston, and he needs somebody to produce it.
大卫·拉德是一位初次尝试的电影制片人。他来自一家名为“拉德制作”的公司，大卫·拉德电影制作公司。他正在制作一部非常低成本的、130万美元的电影，叫《击倒》（The Knockdown），这是一部浪漫喜剧，讲述了一位历史保护主义者试图在一位丰满的年轻建筑师的帮助下拯救一座濒危建筑的故事。所以他要在波士顿拍摄这部电影，他需要找个人来制片。
Before long, Rudder is interviewing a guy named George Moffly for the job. Moffly is 27. He's made some low-budget commercials for a weight loss clinic and a dog racing track. He's worked on the crew of exactly one Hollywood film called Vampire's Kiss with Nicholas Cage. And from the very start, Moffly says, the whole thing seemed a little odd.
没过多久，拉德就面试了一个名叫乔治·莫夫利（George Moffly）的人来担任这份工作。莫夫利27岁。他曾为减肥诊所和赛狗场制作过一些低成本广告。他曾在尼古拉斯·凯奇主演的好莱坞电影《吸血鬼之吻》的剧组工作过。从一开始，莫夫利就说，整件事看起来有点奇怪。
They've sent me the script. It's the worst thing I've ever read in my life. I just can't believe it. I can't believe anything could be that bad. But I didn't care. I wanted to do the movie. I'd set my mind to it. I wanted to produce a film. So whatever it takes.
他们把剧本寄给了我。这是我这辈子读过的最烂的东西。我简直不敢相信。我无法相信有什么东西能烂成这样。但我不在乎。我想拍这部电影。我已经下定决心了。我想制作一部电影。所以无论付出什么代价。
What kind of impression did this David Rudder make on you when you first met him?
你第一次见到大卫·拉德时，他对你印象如何？
We were in a tiny little hotel room with a double bed and just enough room for two chairs, and I was sitting on a chair, practically touching knees with this guy who just, quite honestly, seemed improbable.
我们在一个极小的酒店房间里，里面有一张双人床和仅够放两把椅子的空间，我坐在椅子上，膝盖几乎碰到了这个人的膝盖，老实说，他看起来很不靠谱。
David Rudder makes a kind of shocking impression on George. He's an intimidating guy. He's about six-four, blond, kind of Aryan, square-jawed, very serious.
大卫·拉德给乔治留下了相当震惊的印象。他是一个令人畏惧的家伙。大约六英尺四英寸高，金发，典型的雅利安人，方下巴，非常严肃。
He was in a suit. He just didn't seem to know anything about film. And I had wondered, I said, well, this is really great.  So you're doing a film called The Knockdown. And he was extremely evasive about any concrete details.
他穿着西装。但他似乎对电影一无所知。我当时很好奇，我说，好吧，这真的很棒。所以你要拍一部叫《击倒》的电影。他对于任何具体的细节都极其闪烁其词。
Any country details, you mean like--
任何具体的细节，你是说像——
Who wrote it? A guy. OK. Well, who's the DP? Hmm. And literally, hmm. Not even anything after that. Just hmm.
谁写的剧本？一个家伙。好的。摄影指导是谁？嗯。真的是，嗯。在那之后什么都没有了。只是嗯。
They sit down to the interview, and it immediately takes a peculiar turn. What happens is that David Rudder starts saying to George, have you ever dealt with the Teamsters? You know, in all the movies and commercials that you've worked on, have you ever had to deal with the Teamsters? And the phrase "dealing with the Teamsters" is kind of a wink-wink, nudge-nudge code for, have you ever had to bribe the Teamsters? Which is something that generally you did have to do at that time if you were making a movie in Boston.
他们坐下来面试，情况立即发生了奇怪的转折。大卫·拉德开始对乔治说，你跟卡车司机工会（Teamsters）打过交道吗？你知道，在你工作过的所有电影和广告中，你是否处理过卡车司机工会？而“处理卡车司机工会”这个短语是一种暗示性的暗语，意思是：你有没有贿赂过他们？如果你当时在波士顿拍电影，这通常是你必须做的事情。
And they ask me, have I ever bribed up the Teamsters? And I answer truthfully, yes, I have. And then they ask me, have you ever bribed the Boston teamsters? And I answered truthfully, yeah, uh huh. Then Rudder asked me, have you ever bribed Jimmy Moar or Billy Winn? Now, I knew both of those guys, but the answer was no, I had not.
他们问我是否贿赂过卡车司机工会，我如实回答，是的，我贿赂过。然后他们问我，你有没有贿赂过波士顿的工会成员？我如实回答，是的，嗯哼。然后拉德问我，你有没有贿赂过吉米·摩尔（Jimmy Moar）或比利·温（Billy Winn）？现在，我认识那两个人，但答案是：不，我没有。
And I thought, you know what? I want a job. I want this job. I want to be a producer. So I said, sure, all the time. You know?
我想，你知道吗？我想要这份工作。我想要这份工作。我想成为一名制片人。所以我说，当然，经常贿赂。你知道吗？
And with that, he's given the job.
就这样，他得到了这份工作。
As you've probably figured out by now, this is no ordinary movie. In fact, the movie is just a front for a scheme that is either ingeniously smart or really, really dumb, depending on your point of view.
正如你现在可能已经猜到的那样，这不是普通的电影。事实上，这部电影只是一个计划的掩护，这个计划究竟是天才的聪明还是彻头彻尾的愚蠢，取决于你的观点。
David Rudder, in fact, is not David Rudder. He is FBI Special Agent Garland Schweickhardt. Schweickhardt, for years, has been a pencil-pusher at the FBI, a bureaucrat. But he's come up with this idea for a sting operation. Catch the Teamsters, and prove that they're in bed with the mob.
大卫·拉德，事实上，不是大卫·拉德。他是FBI特工加兰·施威克哈特（Garland Schweickhardt）。多年来，施威克哈特一直是FBI里的一名文职人员，一个官僚。但他想出了这个诱捕行动的构思。抓住卡车司机工会，证明他们与黑手党勾结。
Back when this is happening, back in the late '80s, the Teamsters and the Patriarca crime family seem to be working hand in glove on a lot of things.
当这件事发生时，回到80年代末，卡车司机工会和帕特里亚尔卡（Patriarca）犯罪家族似乎在很多事情上都是紧密合作的。
And they'd been shaking down every movie and film production that had come to Boston and demanding that more teamsters are hired than necessary, threatening the Feds, dumping peoples' trucks in the river, giving money to the mob, and the FBI wanted to catch them at this.
他们对每一部来到波士顿的电影和影片制作进行敲诈，要求雇佣超出必要数量的工会成员，威胁联邦探员，把人们的卡车扔进河里，给黑手党送钱，而FBI想在这些方面抓住他们。
David Rudder, or Special Agent Schweickhardt, had he done undercover work before?
大卫·拉德，也就是施威克哈特特工，他以前做过卧底吗？
He had never done any undercover work before. And this was what he saw as his big career opportunity to be an FBI guy like you see in the movies. He went to the FBI's big crime undercover bureau and managed to convince them to give him $20, $25, $30,000 to start this project.
他以前从来没做过卧底工作。他把这看作是他成为电影中那种FBI探员的重大职业机会。他去了FBI的大型犯罪卧底局，设法说服他们给了他2万、2.5万、3万美元来启动这个项目。
And then he went to film school for a semester at UCLA. Studied in one film class. Learned a lot about the business from that. Went to Paramount Pictures, asked them if they had a dud script that they were never going to use. They handed him this turkey of a script called The Knockdown.
然后他在加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）上了一个学期的电影课。上了一门电影课。从中学到了很多关于电影行业的知识。他去了派拉蒙影业，问他们有没有永远不会用的烂剧本。他们给了他这个叫《击倒》的“火鸡”剧本。
And he was selling himself as a guy who was doing an investment for some friends. And this is a kind of lark. It's an investment project for a small group of dentists in the Alexandria, Virginia, area.
他把自己包装成一个正在为一些朋友进行投资的家伙。这只是一次恶作剧。这是一个为弗吉尼亚州亚历山大市的一小群牙医准备的投资项目。
How early on does Rudder send George to go and talk to the Teamsters?
拉德多早开始派乔治去和卡车司机工会谈话的？
It's the first thing he has George do in his job as his producer. He says to George, go to Jimmy Moar. See what you can do in terms of cutting a deal.
这是他让乔治担任制片人后做的第一件事。他对乔治说，去找吉米·摩尔。看看你在达成协议方面能做什么。
So I was given marching orders to go meet with Jimmy Moar. And the Teamster hall is this red brick, generic, '50s, early '60s building underneath three overpasses. I'm led into the hall through a series of buzzers. Go to a really dim, fake-paneled office where Jimmy Moar is, and he says, so what can I do for you, George?
所以我接到命令去见吉米·摩尔。卡车司机工会的会堂是那座红砖结构、普通的、50年代到60年代初的建筑，位于三座立交桥之下。我被领进大厅，穿过一连串的蜂鸣器。来到一间非常昏暗、贴着假镶板的办公室，吉米·摩尔就在那里，他说，那我能为你做什么，乔治？
He introduces himself. He says, I'm here representing David Rudder. We're making a small film. We only have $1.3 million. The budget is laid out like this. We can only afford to hire seven teamsters. And Jimmy Moar, who is this tough, tough scary guy, says, no. You're going to hire 19. And he wouldn't even come down to like 18.
他做了自我介绍。他说，我是代表大卫·拉德来的。我们在拍一部小电影。我们只有130万美元的预算。预算是这样分配的。我们只能雇得起7名工会成员。而吉米·摩尔，这个强硬、可怕的家伙说，不行。你要雇19个。他甚至不肯降到18个。
He said, well, you know what? 19 is our offer. That's what we're going to do it for.
他说，好吧，你知道吗？19个是我们的报价。我们就是要按这个价钱做。
19 is ridiculous. It would be half the crew of this entire movie. There would be no reason in the world they would need this many people.
19个太荒谬了。那将占到整部电影剧组人员的一半。他们根本没有任何理由需要这么多人。
And George, who's a tough guy in his own right, he got sort of angry about this. And the first thing he did was offer him a deal. He said, look. Can we work out something? Basically said, can I buy you off? Jimmy Moar said he wasn't interested in that. He said, you hire 19 of my guys or you can forget about it, and you can take your [BLEEP] movie to Toronto.
而乔治，他自己也是个强硬的人，对此感到有点生气。他做的第一件事就是提出一项交易。他说，听着。我们可以商量一下吗？基本上是说，我可以买通你吗？吉米·摩尔说他没兴趣。他说，你要么雇佣我这19个人，要么就忘了这事，你可以带着你的[哔——]电影去多伦多。
And I said, you know what? [BLEEP] you. Tell you what. We're just not going to use any Teamsters.
我说，你知道吗？[哔——]你。告诉你吧。我们干脆不用任何工会成员了。
Why don't we do this? Why don't I not hire any Teamsters, I take the money that I saved, I hire a bunch of Pinkerton guards with guns, and I order them around the set to shoot to kill any union disruption that might happen while we're doing this movie.
我们为什么不这样做呢？为什么我不雇佣任何工会成员，把我省下的钱用来雇佣一堆带着枪的平克顿警卫（Pinkerton guards），我命令他们在片场周围巡逻，谁要是敢阻挠拍摄，就直接开枪击毙。
Which was when he offered to break my legs. I'm told to get out of his [BLEEP] office, or he's going to, you know, tear me from limb to limb and throw me in the river.
就在那时，他提出要打断我的腿。我被告知滚出他的[哔——]办公室，否则他会把我大卸八块，扔进河里。
So that was the end of that negotiation. It didn't go very well.
这就是谈判的终结。进行得不太顺利。
And from the FBI point of view, that is not what they wanted to happen. They wanted the bribe to go down.
从FBI的角度来看，这并不是他们想发生的事情。他们想要的是贿赂成功。
From the FBI point of view, it was a total wash. I mean, Jimmy Moar wouldn't even talk about taking a bribe.
从FBI的角度来看，这完全是彻底的失败。我的意思是，吉米·摩尔甚至根本不谈接受贿赂的事。
So I have to call David Rudder, and I tell him, look I'm a failure. I haven't been able to do it.
所以我不得不打电话给大卫·拉德，我告诉他，听着，我是个失败者。我没能成功。
So Rudder, aka Special Agent Garland Schweickhardt, goes back to his bosses at the Los Angeles bureau and says we can't get anywhere with this. It's not working. Maybe this wasn't such a great idea. And the sting operation is canceled.
所以拉德，即施威克哈特特工，回到他在洛杉矶分局的上司那里说，我们在这里什么也办不到。行不通。也许这并不是什么好主意。诱捕行动取消了。
And shortly thereafter, I get a phone call saying that the dentists have pulled out.
不久之后，我接到一个电话，说那些牙医撤资了。
Months go by. Everybody goes back to their regular lives. And then the dentists get a lucky break. A small-time mafia-related thug named Robert Franchi strolls into the FBI office one day and announces that he wants to turn state's evidence and help them nab members of the Patriarca crime family.
几个月过去了。每个人都回到了正常的生活。然后牙医们得到了一个幸运的机会。一个与黑手党有关的小混混罗伯特·弗兰奇（Robert Franchi）有一天溜进了FBI办公室，宣布他想成为污点证人，帮助他们抓捕帕特里亚尔卡犯罪家族的成员。
His motives aren't altruistic, mind you. He doesn't want to rid the world of organized crime. He simply owes some gambling debts to a guy, and that guy has gone out and threatened Franchi's mother. His mother.
请注意，他的动机并不是利他主义的。他并不想从世界上铲除有组织犯罪。他只是欠了一个人赌债，而那个人去威胁弗兰奇的母亲。他的母亲。
And this comes to the attention of Garland Schweickhardt, who still has this dream of this sting operation. And he realizes, this is somebody he could actually use. And he's going to have Robert Franchi approach the Patriarca crime family and say, I've got this friend, he's making a low budget movie in Boston, he doesn't have enough money to deal with the Teamsters. He'd be willing to pay off anybody he has to pay off to save some money on the other end, can you pull some strings with the Teamsters and see if you can help them out. And now that this is happening, they need to make the movie again.
这引起了加兰·施威克哈特的注意，他仍然怀着那个诱捕行动的梦想。他意识到，这是一个他真正可以利用的人。他让罗伯特·弗兰奇接触帕特里亚尔卡犯罪家族，并说：我有一个朋友，他在波士顿拍低成本电影，他没有足够的钱来应付卡车司机工会。他愿意付钱给任何他必须支付的人，以节省另一头的开支，你能利用你与工会的关系看看能不能帮他们一把吗。现在这件事发生了，他们需要再次开始筹拍这部电影。
I actually had moved to New York. I'd left Boston. And I was the location manager on a film called The Ambulance with Eric Roberts. And one day, I'm in the production office and the phone rings, and David Rudder is on the phone, and asks me if I'd be interested in working for him again.
我其实搬到了纽约。我离开了波士顿。我正在一部由埃里克·罗伯茨主演的电影《救护车》（The Ambulance）中担任外景经理。有一天，我在制作办公室，电话响了，大卫·拉德在电话里问我是否愿意再为他工作。
And it wasn't until after I hung up the phone, I thought, how did he get this number? That's weird. Which was something that, over the course of the next year and a half, would happen a lot.
直到挂了电话我才想到，他是怎么弄到这个号码的？真奇怪。这在接下来的一年半里发生过很多次。
So he flies you to California, right?
所以他把你飞到了加州，对吧？
I'm delighted. I mean, I'm flying to LA.
我很高兴。我的意思是，我要飞往洛杉矶。
Had you ever been flown anywhere on business?
你以前有过因为工作而被飞到任何地方吗？
No.
没有。
Does he meet you at the airport?
他在机场接你了吗？
Yeah. David pulls up in a gold Rolls Royce. I'm just like, I can't believe it. I mean, this guy's for real.
是的。大卫开着一辆金色的劳斯莱斯过来。我当时想，我简直不敢相信。我的意思是，这家伙是来真的。
It's just this real Hollywood moment. Of course he doesn't know, or have any way of knowing, that the bronze Rolls Royce actually used to belong to a major drug kingpin, that it's seized federal property, and that David is borrowing it just for the day to impress George and make it look like he's a real Hollywood guy.
这真是一个真正的好莱坞时刻。当然，他不知道，也没有任何办法知道，这辆古铜色的劳斯莱斯其实曾经属于一个大毒枭，它是被查封的联邦财产，而大卫只是为了这一天借了它来给乔治留下深刻印象，让他看起来像个真正的好莱坞人。
So they continue driving through Hollywood, and they get to this very nondescript office building, and there's a parking space there that says, Reserved for David Rudder Productions. They go up into the elevator, and George starts to feel this sinking feeling that maybe this guy isn't such a big shot, because the office building is filled with nothing but medical practices and biopsy labs. And it's just not the kind of place you would think that a Hollywood guy would have an office.
所以他们继续开车穿过好莱坞，来到了一座非常普通的办公楼，那里有一个停车位，上面写着“预留给大卫·拉德制作公司”。他们乘电梯上去，乔治开始感到一种沉重的感觉，也许这家伙不是什么大人物，因为这栋办公楼里塞满了医疗诊所和活检实验室。这根本不是你认为好莱坞大人物会有的办公室所在地。
And once he opens the door to his office, this skanky orange-carpeted weird place, it's got posters all over the walls of movies that David Rudder clearly did not produce. You know, like Biloxi Blues and Clan of the Cave Bear.
一旦他打开办公室的门，那个铺着廉价橙色地毯的怪地方，墙上贴满了大卫·拉德显然没制作过的电影海报。你知道，像《比洛克西小调》（Biloxi Blues）和《火种》（Clan of the Cave Bear）。
And then he brings me into his office, which is nothing. There are no papers. There was no sign. There are no pictures of his wife. There was no anything.
然后他把我带进他的办公室，里面什么都没有。没有文件。没有标志。没有他妻子的照片。什么都没有。
No computer?
没有电脑？
No computer, nothing personal. Just an empty desk and a filing cabinet.
没有电脑，什么私人物品都没有。只有一张空桌子和一个文件柜。
Still, it's not like anybody else is offering George a producing job and a producing credit in a movie, so he says yes-- on one condition. He insists that they get a better script.
尽管如此，又不是别人在给乔治提供制片人的工作和电影制片人的头衔，所以他答应了——但有一个条件。他坚持要求他们弄到一个更好的剧本。
So first they tried to get somebody to rewrite The Knockdown for $5,000, and then, when that fails--
所以他们先是试图找人用5000美元改写《击倒》，然后，当那失败后——
He says to David Rudder, look. You know, if you want to make a movie that's going to work, it's not going to be this movie. And why don't you give me $20,000 and send me out there to find a script that's actually decent so that we can get good actors in it, so that we can get good people to work on it, and so that we can make some money on it later. And he convinces him to cough up another $20,000 of US taxpayer money to go buy a new movie script for this scam movie that the FBI's making.
他对大卫·拉德说，听着。你知道，如果你想拍一部能成功的电影，那绝不会是这一部。你为什么不给我2万美元，把我派出去找一个真正像样的剧本，这样我们就能找好演员，找好工作人员，以后还能赚点钱。他成功说服了他再从美国纳税人的钱里挤出2万美元去买一个新的电影剧本，为了FBI正在制作的这部诈骗电影。
It's amazing. Because from the FBI's point of view, this movie is still never going to be made.
这真是太惊人了。因为从FBI的角度来看，这部电影根本永远不会被拍出来。
Right. But at this moment, this is where the story turns. Because at this moment, David Rudder starts to have an ulterior motive, which is that he really wants to make a movie. You know, he's been hanging around this business for about a year now. He's interested. He thinks it's exciting. It's glamorous. And in the back of his mind, he's thinking, you know, we might actually film this thing. And he seals the deal by shaking George's hand and saying, "Let's make a movie we can be proud of." And you know what? He meant it. He really wanted to at that point.
对。但就在这一刻，故事发生了转折。因为在这一刻，大卫·拉德开始有了不可告人的动机，那就是他真的想拍一部电影。你知道，他已经在这一行混了一年左右了。他很有兴趣。他觉得这很刺激。这很光鲜。在他的潜意识里，他想，你知道，我们说不定真的能把它拍出来。他通过握住乔治的手说：“让我们拍一部我们能引以为傲的电影吧”来达成协议。你知道吗？他是认真的。当时他真的想拍。
Why? What was his vision of how this could go? Like, what was going to happen if they made this into a movie?
为什么？他对这件事会怎么发展有什么愿景？比如，如果他们真的把它拍成电影会发生什么？
Well, the vision that he had was bigger than what he had admitted to the FBI. What he had started thinking, as he was understanding more about the movie-making business was, you know, we could continue doing this in other states. And what he thought was, you take the initial seed money that the FBI gave him, you actually make the film, you sell the film, you sell it to HBO, you sell it to the airlines, you put it in some festivals, you make some money off it, it goes to video.
嗯，他所持有的愿景比他向FBI承认的要大。随着他对电影制作行业的深入了解，他开始想到，你知道，我们可以在其他州继续这样做。他的想法是，你拿FBI给你的初始种子资金，真的把电影拍出来，把电影卖掉，卖给HBO，卖给航空公司，参加一些电影节，赚点钱，再做成录像带。
With those profits, you go to another state like Nevada, where they also have this same problem with the Teamsters and the mob, and you make another fake movie. And then you take the profits from that and you go to California to do it again. And he had this vision that he was going to become, like, a studio executive in the studio system. He was going to use profits from one film to make another film, and each time he was doing it, he was going to bring down the mob in another state.
利用这些利润，你去另一个州，比如内华达州，那里也有同样的问题，卡车司机工会和黑手党勾结，你再拍一部假电影。然后你再拿那里的利润去加州再做一次。他有一种愿景，他要成为电影体系里的一名制片厂高管。他要利用一部电影的利润去制作另一部，每次他这样做的时候，他都要在另一个州打掉黑手党。
He's excited about casting. He starts fantasizing about the kind of people that we can get in the part. Academy Awards. He mentions that a few times.
他对选角很兴奋。他开始幻想我们能得到什么样的演员。奥斯卡奖。他提过几次。
Wow.
哇。
He's really-- I'll tell you something. He is excited about being a producer.
他真的——我告诉你一件事。他真的对当制片人感到很兴奋。
When George is talking to him about the movie, does he ask him, like, well, do you have any name actors attached to this? Does he ask him the basic questions?
当乔治和他谈论这部电影时，他问过他，比如，你有没有请到什么名演员加入？他问过他这些基本问题吗？
He does. One of the reasons that George is so excited about doing the movie is that he's told that Brian Dennehy is really interested in being in it, and so is Rebecca De Mornay. As it turns out later, of course, that's a complete fiction. Although I would love to know how they come up with those two names out of--
他问了。乔治对做这部电影感到如此兴奋的原因之一是，他被告知布莱恩·丹内利（Brian Dennehy）真的很有兴趣参与其中，丽贝卡·德·莫妮（Rebecca De Mornay）也一样。当然，结果证明，那完全是虚构的。虽然我很想知道他们是怎么从——
I know.  They seem so random.
我知道。他们看起来太随机了。
--everybody, they're so specific.
——所有人中想到那两个名字的，它们太具体了。
But no, Dennehy is perfect in a way. Because you've heard of him, but you just don't think he'd be that hard to get.
但不是，丹内利在某种程度上是完美的。因为你听说过他，但你就是觉得他不会太难请到。
And Rebecca De Mornay, by 1989, wasn't doing a lot of work. You know, she might have considered it.
而丽贝卡·德·莫妮，到1989年时，并没有什么工作。你知道，她可能考虑过。
Really, you think actually, we could get her on the phone. In a way, it's brilliant. It's perfect. That part of it is actually like perfectly well thought through.
真的，你觉得实际上，我们可以把她请到电话里来。在某种程度上，这很棒。很完美。那一部分其实策划得非常周全。
So while all of this is happening, meanwhile, Rudder is working the mob connection, and he's meeting more mobsters. And just talk about how the monsters are reacting to the idea of this movie coming to town.
所以当这一切发生时，与此同时，拉德在运作黑手党的联系，他见到了更多的黑帮分子。谈谈黑帮分子对这部电影即将来到镇上的反应吧。
Well, you know, this is the sparkle of show business. The mobsters get really into the idea of being part of this movie. Franchi starts bringing David Rudder around. He has some dinners on Raymond Patriarca's yacht. He meets some people.
嗯，你知道，这就是演艺界的魅力。黑帮分子对参与这部电影的想法非常感兴趣。弗兰奇开始带大卫·拉德四处走动。他在雷蒙德·帕特里亚尔卡（Raymond Patriarca）的游艇上吃了几顿饭。他见到了一些人。
As the production moves forward, a host of bizarre people start coming in to account.
随着制作的推进，一大群奇奇怪怪的人开始参与进来。
One of them in particular is this kid who's real handsome in an early days Travolta kind of way, Italian Stallion sort of thing going on, named Frankie Salemme Jr. He's a tough guy, he's a little mob runner, but he's also really into show business, and he's taken a few acting classes in this life. And so Raymond Patriarca says to David Rudder, you know what, I want to help out with this movie as much as I can. Maybe you can use my speedboat. We could put my speedboat in the movie. It would be really cool to see my speedboat in a real movie. And I think you should hire Frankie here to be the speedboat driver for the movie role. So suddenly the movie's got a speedboat and a speedboat driver in it. But all these guys just want to be part of the picture.
其中特别有一个年轻人，长得很有早年特拉沃尔塔那种英俊的劲头，有点意大利种马的感觉，名字叫弗兰基·萨勒梅二世（Frankie Salemme Jr.）。他是个硬汉，是个小黑帮信使，但他也非常热衷于演艺事业，这辈子上过几个表演课。所以雷蒙德·帕特里亚尔卡对大卫·拉德说，你知道吗，我想尽可能多地帮助这部电影。也许你可以用我的快艇。我们可以把我的快艇放进电影里。能在真正的电影里看到我的快艇会很酷。而且我觉得你应该雇佣弗兰基去当电影里的快艇驾驶员。所以突然间，电影里有了快艇和快艇驾驶员。但这些家伙都只想成为影片的一部分。
While all this is going on, George finds another script-- using $20,000 of your and my tax money-- and they start to hire a crew, build sets, scout locations, to film  the movie in Providence. But weird things keep happening.
在这一切发生的同时，乔治找到了另一个剧本——用了你和我的2万美元税款——他们开始雇佣剧组人员、搭建布景、勘察外景，准备在普罗维登斯拍摄这部电影。但奇怪的事情不断发生。
I get a call from Rudder. I've got a crew, and I have to pay them every week. And I say, I need a check. I've set up a bank account, or we need to set up a bank account.
我接到拉德的电话。我有一个剧组，我必须每周支付他们的工资。我说，我需要支票。我已经开设了一个银行账户，或者我们需要开设一个银行账户。
So he flies in. And rather than pay with a check, he has a suitcase, which we take to the bank. And then he asks the bank guy, what's the maximum I can deposit without reporting to the Feds? The guy says-- I think it was $10,000. So Rutter opens the suitcase and there is-- I don't how many tens of thousands of dollars in that suitcase. Which he then counts out, whatever, $9,000, and hands to the bank guy, who is as dumbfounded as I am.
所以他飞过来了。他没有用支票支付，而是带了一个手提箱，我们把它带到了银行。然后他问银行人员，我存入的最高金额是多少而不需要向联邦政府报告？那个人说——我想是1万美元。所以拉德打开手提箱，里面有——我不知道有多少万美元。他然后数出9000美元，交给银行人员，那个人和我一样目瞪口呆。
Schweickhardt works for the federal government. Like, what kind of undercover man is he that he doesn't know, well, if you deposit more than $10,000, it shows up in reporting? Like, I know that just from watching TV.
施威克哈特为联邦政府工作。我的意思是，他是什么样的卧底人员，连存款超过1万美元会出现在报告里都不知道？像我这种只是看电视的人都知道。
So much of this is so sloppy. When I interviewed Schweickhardt years later, when I was working on the story, I said to him, you know, what was the deal with not wanting the IRS to know about it? He said, you know what? It's just so much paperwork once you get the IRS involved. And I thought, he's just like the rest of us.
这里面有太多的疏忽。多年后，当我在做这个报道采访施威克哈特时，我对他说，你知道，不想让国税局（IRS）知道是怎么回事？他说，你知道吗？一旦涉及到国税局，就有太多的文书工作了。我心想，他和我们其他人没什么两样。
David Rudder is convincing enough to the mob guys, though. The movie looks real to them. And pretty soon, the sting goes down, just as planned. The FBI records Rudder paying $25,000 in cash to the mobsters as a fee for making their movie, without 19 Teamsters working on it.
不过，大卫·拉德对那些黑帮分子来说确实足够有说服力。在他们眼里，这部电影看起来是真的。很快，诱捕行动按计划进行了。FBI录下了拉德支付2.5万美元现金给黑帮分子作为拍摄他们电影的费用，而且没有让那19个卡车司机工会的人工作。
And at that point, the FBI has what it needs to make its case in court. In theory, they should shut the film production down the next day, because there's no purpose now. But they don't shut it down, because Rudder really wants to make his movie.
在那一点上，FBI已经有了在法庭上提起诉讼所需的证据。理论上，他们第二天就应该叫停电影制作，因为现在已经没意义了。但他们没有叫停，因为拉德真的想拍他的电影。
How serious does it get? Do they start auditioning actors? Like, are there name actors who are showing up for this?
严重到什么程度？他们开始面试演员了吗？比如，有没有名演员出现？
Apparently there are. Apparently Bebe Neuwirth comes in for a reading, and there was somebody else-- oh, John Lithgow comes in for a reading. They're auditioning people for extras. They're bringing in this whole parade of actors, day after day.
显然有。显然碧碧·纽沃斯（Bebe Neuwirth）来试镜了，还有别人——哦，约翰·利特高（John Lithgow）也来试镜了。他们日复一日地面试群众演员。他们带来了整整一队的演员。
At this point Robert the Neck-- Robert Franchi, who is the key to this whole operation, who is the mob informant-- starts to be the only person in this whole story who has a crisis of conscience. Because he's watching, as he would describe it later, these really idealistic young kids come in and audition for what they think is a real movie. And he feels like there's something really wrong about that, you know? He knows that it's not a real movie. He knows that the FBI is behind it. He knows it's probably never going to get made. And he's a standup guy. He just feels like-- he's the same guy who was going to kill somebody for threatening his mother, you know? He just, he's got values.
在这一点上，罗伯特·弗兰奇——罗伯特“颈脖”（Robert the Neck），他是整个行动的关键，是黑手党的告密者——开始成为这个故事中唯一一个有良心危机的人。因为他在看着，正如他后来描述的那样，这些非常有理想的年轻人来参加他们认为是一部真实电影的试镜。他觉得这真的很不对劲，你知道吗？他知道这不是一部真实的电影。他知道FBI在背后操纵。他知道它可能永远拍不出来。而他是个讲义气的人。他只是觉得——他就是那个曾经要因为别人威胁他母亲而杀掉某个家伙的人，你知道吗？他只是，他有他的价值观。
The other thing that happens around this time is that George starts to get in some run-ins. George is a really scrappy little guy. He starts to get in some run-ins with these mob guys who are hanging around the movie set. And he had hired his little sister to work as a production assistant on this film, and Frankie Salemme Jr. keeps hitting on her, and she's scared of him, because he's a really scary, thuggish guy, and he won't leave her alone. So George goes to his sister's defense, as both an older brother and a movie producer, and takes Salemme aside and says--
此时发生的另一件事是乔治开始遇到一些冲突。乔治是个非常倔强的家伙。他开始与那些在片场周围徘徊的黑帮分子发生冲突。他雇了他妹妹来担任这部电影的制片助理，而弗兰基·萨勒梅二世一直在骚扰她，她很怕他，因为他是个非常吓人、暴力的家伙，他不肯放过她。所以乔治作为哥哥和电影制片人挺身而出保护妹妹，把萨勒梅拉到一边说——
If you look at my sister again, if you touch my sister again, if you touch anybody on the set, look at anybody on the set, I'm going to slap you with a sexual harassment suit that's going to make your head spin around. Which is when he told me, you know, you don't know who I [BLEEP] am. You don't know who my [BLEEP] father is. You know, I'm going to [BLEEP] kill you.
如果你再看我妹妹一眼，如果你再碰我妹妹一下，如果你再碰片场里的任何人，看片场里的任何人一眼，我就要给你扣上性骚扰的官司，让你晕头转向。就在那时他告诉我，你知道，你不知道我是谁[哔——]。你不知道我爸是谁[哔——]。你知道，我要[哔——]杀了你。
For this family, that's not just a colorful expression. That's actually like a way of life. You know?
对这个家族来说，那不仅仅是一个色彩丰富的表达。那实际上是一种生活方式。你知道吗？
That's actually a statement of intent. That's a contract, right there.
那实际上是一个意图声明。那是一份合同，就在那里。
They will find you-- fresh kills. You know? And so he sort of almost tries to make good on it one night. George doesn't find this out until years later, when the whole story comes out. George is doing some work in his hotel room, drawing up budgets, and Frankie Salemme comes upstairs with the intention-- he would admit later-- of throwing him out a window and killing him.
他们会找到你——新鲜的杀戮。你知道吗？所以他几乎有一天试图实现这个承诺。乔治直到几年后整个故事曝光才发现这一点。乔治在酒店房间里工作，起草预算，弗兰基·萨勒梅上了楼，带着意图——他后来承认——把他从窗户扔出去杀了他。
And he is stopped in the hallway by our hero, Robert the Neck. Robert Franchi, the mob informant, tackles him in the hallway and talks him out of it and says, why don't you cool down, it's not that big a deal, he's just a punk, you don't want anything to do with it, and sends him on his way. So Robert the Neck is turning out to be the sort of moral center of this whole event.
他在走廊被我们的英雄，罗伯特“颈脖”拦住了。黑手党告密者罗伯特·弗兰奇在走廊里制服了他，劝阻了他，并说，你为什么不冷静一下，这不是什么大不了的事，他只是个混混，你不想和他有任何瓜葛，然后把他打发走了。所以罗伯特“颈脖”成为了整个事件中某种道德核心。
So at what point do they finally pull the plug?
那么他们最终在什么时候拔掉插头的？
They pull the plug two weeks before they're supposed to go into production. And what happens is that somebody at the Justice Department is reviewing case files for undercover work for the FBI and discovers that the FBI is about to make a film in New England starring real actors in order to entrap the mob.
他们在预定进入制作的前两周拔掉了插头。事情是司法部有人在审查FBI的卧底工作案件卷宗时发现，FBI即将要在新英格兰拍摄一部由真正的演员主演的电影，目的是诱捕黑手党。
And they pull the plug on it within an hour. You know, they've made a series of frantic phone calls saying, whose idea is this? This is an incredibly bad idea. We could all get sued, at the very least. And some people could get killed. Some of these innocent people who've been put in between the teamsters, the FBI, and the mob. This is a very dangerous thing to involve citizens with.
他们在不到一个小时内就拔掉了插头。你知道，他们打了一连串疯狂的电话说，这是谁的主意？这是一个极其糟糕的主意。我们所有人都可能被起诉，至少是这样。而且有些人可能会被杀。这些无辜的人被置于卡车司机工会、FBI和黑手党之间。让公民参与进来是一件非常危险的事情。
And Schweickhardt fights for it with his life. And one of the things that he's told by the FBI is that the Justice Department feels that it could be an embarrassment to the federal government to find out that taxpayer money had been used to make a crappy low-budget movie. At which point Schweickhardt says, but it's going to be a really good movie.
施威克哈特用生命为它抗争。FBI告诉他的一件事是，司法部认为发现纳税人的钱被用来制作一部烂的低成本电影，可能会让联邦政府感到尴尬。此时施威克哈特说，但它会是一部非常好的电影。
Aww.
噢。
You know? Like he's so hurt that they would think that he wasn't going to make a really good movie. He's like, it's not anything that anybody would be embarrassed about. It's going to be a really, really good movie script. It's a great script.
你知道吗？就像他听到他们认为他拍不出好电影而感到受伤一样。他说，这不是任何会让任何人感到尴尬的事情。这将是一个非常、非常好的电影剧本。这是一个伟大的剧本。
This argument does not carry the day with the United States Justice Department. Rudder has to call George and tell him that the dentists have pulled out again. George is crushed. Rudder is crushed. Everybody on the film gets fired.
这个论点在美国司法部面前并没有奏效。拉德不得不打电话给乔治，告诉他牙医们又撤资了。乔治崩溃了。拉德崩溃了。电影里的每个人都被解雇了。
A year and a half passes before George Moffly finally gets told what it was all about, when the Justice Department contacts him and asks him to testify to a secret grand jury about the movie. He declines that invitation. Being lied to for two years, working on a fake movie, and nearly getting thrown out of a window made him feel like he'd served the country enough already.
又过了一年半，当司法部联系他要求他就这部电影向秘密大陪审团作证时，乔治·莫夫利终于知道了这一切是怎么回事。他拒绝了那个邀请。被欺骗了两年，在一部假电影上工作，而且差点被扔出窗外，让他觉得他已经为国家服务得够多了。
The Justice Department does OK in court. Not great. Only one guy goes to prison. But the whole case scares the Teamsters and the mob in New England enough that in the end, despite everything that was wrong-headed and ill-conceived about Garland Schweickhardt's original plan, it actually achieves what it set out to do. The mob and the Teamsters stopped shaking down film crews in New England. So maybe the plan wasn't so crazy, though it might have been smart to change a few of the details.
司法部在法庭上表现得还行。不算太好。只有一个人进了监狱。但整个案件足以让新英格兰的卡车司机工会和黑手党感到害怕，最终，尽管加兰·施威克哈特最初的计划中有很多错误和考虑不周的地方，它实际上达到了预期的目的。黑手党和卡车司机工会停止了在新英格兰敲诈电影剧组。所以也许这个计划并没有那么疯狂，尽管如果能改变一些细节可能会更聪明。
Coming up. Girl meets boy, girl loses boy, girl concocts far-fetched but weirdly possibly effective MacGyver-like scheme concerning boy. In a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来。女孩遇上男孩，女孩失去男孩，女孩为了男孩炮制了一个牵强但奇怪地可能有效的类似马盖先的计划。芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台节目继续，稍后回来。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, ingenious MacGyver-like schemes, real ones. Some of them, like this next one, invented by people like you and me. We are at Act Four of our program.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，充满独创性的马盖先式计划，真实的那些。其中一些，像接下来这个，是由像你我这样的人发明的。我们现在是节目的第四幕。
Act Four. A Girl's Guide to Mending the Unmendable. Susan Burton tells the story.
第四幕。女孩的修补指南。苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）讲述了这个故事。
The summer I graduated from high school, I had a boyfriend who now, years later, I think of as a creep. Since he had my husband's name, I won't call him that. Instead I'll call him what I called him later, which is Shane.
我高中毕业那年夏天，有个男朋友，现在，多年以后，我觉得他是个卑鄙小人。既然他和我丈夫同名，我就不那样称呼他了。相反，我叫他后来我给他的称呼，那就是肖恩（Shane）。
Shane was my friend Lisa's older brother. I was 17, and he was 23. Shane was the only person I'd ever been friends with who had been alive in the 1960s. Of course, he'd only been a toddler, but that wasn't the way I thought about it. Shane was so old that he'd been alive in history.
肖恩是我朋友丽莎（Lisa）的哥哥。我17岁，他23岁。肖恩是我认识的唯一一个在1960年代活过的人。当然，他当时只是个蹒跚学步的孩子，但我不是这么想的。肖恩太老了，他经历过历史。
Shane was also the first person I knew who'd been engaged. The girl he'd been engaged to was named Kathy. They lived together during college, but then she ran off with the manager of Wild Oats, the local health food store. It sounded to me like Kathy was a hippie.
肖恩也是我认识的第一个订过婚的人。他订婚的对象叫凯西（Kathy）。他们大学时同居过，但后来她跟当地健康食品店“野燕麦”（Wild Oats）的经理跑了。在我听来，凯西是个嬉皮士。
I worked at a health food store too, but my health food store was called Alfalfa's, and it was the type of place where there was less hummus and more pate. There were a lot of Colorado moms in Volvos. I would watch them as they wrote checks. They had big diamond engagement rings from earlier that they now had to figure out how to coordinate with the turquoise jewelry they'd discovered when they moved to the West later in life. One lady, every time she came in, bought lobster salad and leaned in to tell me, "Dear, you wear turquoise very well." I would smile.
我也在一家健康食品店工作，但我的健康食品店叫“紫花苜蓿”（Alfalfa's），那是一个鹰嘴豆泥比较少、肉酱比较多的地方。有很多开着沃尔沃的科罗拉多妈妈。我看着她们开支票。她们有早期买的大钻戒，现在她们不得不设法把钻戒和她们晚年搬到西部后发现的绿松石首饰搭配起来。有一位女士，每次来买龙虾沙拉时，都会凑近跟我说：“亲爱的，你戴绿松石很合适。”我会微笑。
I loved everything about Alfalfa's. I loved imagining the lives of the people in my line. I would talk to them about their groceries. "What do you think of that soy cheese pizza?" I would say. Or, "I really like those Rice Dream moon pies."
我喜欢“紫花苜蓿”的一切。我喜欢想象排在我队里的人的生活。我会跟他们谈论他们的杂货。“你觉得那个豆奶酪披萨怎么样？”我会说。或者，“我真的很喜欢那些大米梦月饼。”
One morning that summer I looked up and Shane was in my line. It was the first time we'd been together, by ourselves, without his sister. He was holding a single can of all-natural dog food. "I ran out of food for the dogs," he said. Instead of putting the can on the counter, like most people did, he put it right into my hand.
那个夏天的一个早晨，我抬头一看，肖恩在我队里。这是我们第一次没有他妹妹在场，单独在一起。他手里拿着一罐纯天然狗粮。“我给狗喂的食物吃完了，”他说。他没有像大多数人那样把罐头放在柜台上，而是直接放在我手里。
And then it started. Shane was the best boyfriend I'd ever had. I felt so grown up, walking across the lawn to his two-story condo, wearing lipstick and cowboy boots. He would be there inside, reading a book on the couch with his two dogs. He'd jump up and kiss me and open me a beer, which he could buy at Liquor Mart himself. We'd sit and talk, and every so often, he'd go to the bookshelf, and soon I'd have a whole stack in front of me. There were so many books he wanted me to read, and movies he wanted me to see. It was like a project to cram it all in.
然后，一切就开始了。肖恩是我有过最好的男朋友。我感觉自己长大了，穿着口红和牛仔靴，穿过草坪走到他那栋两层公寓。他会在里面，坐在沙发上和他的两只狗读书。他会跳起来吻我，给我开一瓶啤酒，他自己就能在酒类超市买到。我们会坐着聊天，每隔一会儿，他就会去书架，很快我面前就堆了一堆书。他有很多书想让我读，很多电影想让我看。这就像是一个要把所有东西都塞进去的项目。
I'd ride my bike home from Alfalfa's at night and he'd surprise me. Be there outside my house in his car, the windows down, playing, very softly, one of my favorite songs. I'd get in the car and we'd start driving, and he'd look over at me in the passenger seat and tell me the thing I was doing with my thumbs was a known sign of genius. He thought I would be the one in of my class to become famous first.
晚上我骑自行车从“紫花苜蓿”回家，他会给我惊喜。出现在我房子外面，摇下车窗，非常轻柔地播放我最喜欢的歌之一。我会上车，我们开始开车，他会看着坐在副驾驶座上的我，告诉我我用拇指做动作是天才的标志。他认为我是我们班里第一个成名的人。
Soon it was time for me to go to college and for Shane to go back to his job teaching at a junior high. Before I left, Shane wrote me a poem and give me a silver barrette from one of the Native American jewelry stores. Flying across the plains in August, fingering the barrette in my hair, I decided I would miss Shane, but not in a terminal, serious, sad girl way. It had been a perfect summer.
很快我就要去上大学了，肖恩也要回去初中教书。我离开前，肖恩给我写了一首诗，并送了我一枚来自当地美洲原住民珠宝店的银发夹。八月飞越平原时，摸着头发上的发夹，我决定我会想念肖恩，但不是那种绝望的、严肃的、忧伤的女孩方式。那是一个完美的夏天。
Then I was at school. It was the last year before email really took off, and everyone still wrote letters. I had good letters. Once Shane drew a cartoon of his dogs over the flap. "The boys say hi!" Another time he wrote, "As soon as I sealed this, I felt like writing more." And one time he wrote, "I love you very much."
然后我就在学校了。那是电子邮件真正流行起来的前一年，每个人还在写信。我收到了很好的信。有一次肖恩在信封盖上画了一张他狗的卡通画。“孩子们问好！”另一次他写道，“我刚封上信就想写更多。”还有一次他写道，“我非常爱你。”
I thought about this a lot. We'd never said it to each other in real life, but now I didn't know. I wondered. I thought that maybe I had underestimated my feelings for Shane. Instead of thinking of him less, I was thinking of him more. Unfortunately, his letters decreased in direct proportion to my thoughts. Worst, in his last notes, he'd begun to mention a first-grade teacher named Tina.
我经常想这件事。我们在现实生活中从没对彼此说过，但现在我不知道了。我很好奇。我以为也许我低估了对肖恩的感情。我不仅没少想他，反而想得更多了。遗憾的是，他的信随着我思绪的增加而直接减少了。最糟糕的是，在他最后的便条里，他开始提到一位叫蒂娜（Tina）的一年级老师。
One night I brought the cordless phone up to my top bunk and I called him. He said, "Well, I have some good news. I'm getting married, to Tina, the first-grade teacher." And that was when I knew-- I loved Shane.
一天晚上，我带着无绳电话上了上铺，给他打了电话。他说，“嗯，我有个好消息。我要结婚了，和蒂娜，那个一年级老师。”就在那一刻，我知道了——我爱肖恩。
Back home in Boulder for the summer, I couldn't get Shane out of my head. Wearing a skirt, I would ride my muddy mountain bike fast up Arapahoe Road, which I knew he had to drive on a lot, hoping he would see me. I thought the skirt plus the mud made me look wild and pretty at the same time. At night, I'd tilt my halogen bike light upward so that it would cast a mysterious glow upon my face. I'd lean forward, peddling furiously. Drive by, Shane, I'd think. Drive by and see me.
夏天回到博尔德，我满脑子都是肖恩。穿着裙子，我飞快地骑着满是泥巴的山地车冲上阿拉帕霍路（Arapahoe Road），我知道他经常开车经过那里，希望他能看到我。我觉得裙子加上泥巴让我看起来狂野又漂亮。晚上，我会把卤素自行车灯向上斜，让它在我的脸上投下一道神秘的光芒。我前倾身体，疯狂踩踏。开过去，肖恩，我想。开过去看到我。
Sometimes in this fantasy, it was Tina who would notice. "Look at that girl on her bike," she'd say. "Look at how fast she's going. And she's so pretty." And Shane would glance away from the road, and it would be me. There would be a silence as he turned back to the wheel, him deciding. They'd slow down at the light. He'd get in the left lane, turn on his blinker. "That's Susan," he'd finally say. "That's Susan?" Tina would say, whipping around just in time to catch me flying over a hill, my hair the lightest thing in the dark night.
有时候在这个幻想里，蒂娜会注意到。“看那个骑车的女孩，”她会说。“看她骑多快。而且她那么漂亮。”而肖恩会从路上移开目光，那人就是我。在他转回方向盘时会有片刻沉默，他会做决定。他们在红绿灯处减速。他会进入左车道，打开转向灯。“那是苏珊，”他最终会说。“那是苏珊？”蒂娜会转过身，正好赶上我飞过山坡，我的头发是漆黑夜晚里最明亮的东西。
And then they would drive back to his parents' house, Shane filled with regret, Tina feeling inadequate. And the next day, while Tina was out, he'd be overcome. He would come to buy a can of dog food at Alfalfa's.
然后他们会开车回他父母家，肖恩充满悔恨，蒂娜感到自卑。第二天，当蒂娜出去时，他会无法抑制自己。他会来“紫花苜蓿”买一罐狗粮。
This summer, not even Alfalfa's was fun. The new darling of the front end was a high school sophomore whose father kissed her goodbye outside the automatic doors each morning. The woman who had been so impressed with my ability to wear turquoise seemed not to recognize me when I rang up her lobster salad. I'd stand there in my apron, frowning over products that had once delighted me, like Frookies, and dreaming of the day Shane would stop by.
那个夏天，连“紫花苜蓿”都不好玩了。收银台的新宠是一个高中二年级学生，她父亲每天早晨都在自动门外吻别她。那位曾经对我的绿松石首饰佩戴能力印象深刻的女士，在我为她的龙虾沙拉结账时，似乎认不出我了。我会穿着围裙站在那里，皱着眉头看着那些曾经让我快乐的产品，比如Frookies，并梦想着肖恩有一天会顺道过来。
But it never, ever happened. He never even came in for just one look. I'd become a completely different girl. Less shiny, less charming, less likely to become famous.
但他从来没来过，一次也没有。他甚至没有来看过一眼。我已经变成了一个完全不同的女孩。不那么闪亮，不那么迷人，也不太可能成名。
One day I resolved to get over Shane before the wedding. It seemed important not to think about him once he was married. Pathetic, but wrong too, in a way that was possibly actionable. The problem was I had no idea how to go about it.
有一天，我下定决心要在婚礼前忘掉肖恩。一旦他结婚了，不去想他似乎很重要。很可怜，但某种程度上也是错的，甚至可能具有某种行动意义。问题是我根本不知道该怎么做。
The one bright spot in my summer was my fiction writing workshop. I'd signed up for a class at the University of Colorado that met two evenings a week. One evening I rode home thinking about my story, "Sunday Morning." "Sunday Morning" was told in the voice of a 12-year-old girl whose parents were on the verge of divorce. Like every story I'd ever written, it was based on a real-life experience.
我夏天唯一的亮点是小说写作研讨会。我报名参加了科罗拉多大学的一门课，每周两个晚上上课。一天晚上我骑车回家，想着我的故事《周日早晨》。《周日早晨》是以一个12岁女孩的声音讲述的，她的父母处于离婚边缘。像我写过的每一个故事一样，它基于现实生活经验。
In one part of the story, I said that the house was always cold, because the father didn't like to waste money on the heating bill. In another part, I mentioned a photograph of girls in matching dresses at the country club. These were just regular old details from my childhood, but the class had seized on them. They thought the country club symbolized an earlier, golden era, and the cold house meant that now the money was gone, and soon the family would be too.
故事中有一部分，我说房子总是很冷，因为父亲不喜欢在取暖费上浪费钱。在另一部分，我提到了乡村俱乐部里女孩们穿着搭配衣服的照片。这些只是我童年时代普通的老细节，但课堂抓住了它们。他们认为乡村俱乐部象征着一个更早的黄金时代，而冰冷的房子意味着现在钱没了，很快家庭也要散了。
Now, swooping down the bike path, I considered whether, in addition to not getting along, my parents had been losing money. It wasn't a point I had intended to make, but it was right there in the details for the class to discover. They could see things about your life that you couldn't. They could tell you things about your own world that you haven't realized.
现在，飞驰在自行车道上，我考虑着父母除了不和睦之外，是不是还一直在亏钱。这不是我想要强调的观点，但细节就在那里，等着课堂去发现。他们可以看到你生活中你自己看不到的东西。他们可以告诉你一些你自己世界里你还没意识到的人事。
And that's when I got the idea. I would write the exact story of my relationship with Shane, the lost, magic summer, him set to marry Tina, the way I couldn't get over him now. I would introduce the class to me, the static protagonist, and they would tell me how to act. They would not only tell me how to get over Shane. They would tell me why it had all happened, what it all meant. I would tell them my own story, and they would explain it to me.
就在那时我有了主意。我要写下我和肖恩关系的真实故事，那个迷失的、魔法般的夏天，他即将与蒂娜结婚，以及我为何现在还忘不掉他。我会把这个班介绍给我，这个静态的受害者，他们会告诉我该怎么做。他们不仅会告诉我如何忘掉肖恩。他们会告诉我为什么这一切都发生了，这一切意味着什么。我会告诉他们我自己的故事，而他们会向我解释。
The next morning, during my shift at Alfalfa's, I sipped from a giant glass of hot tea with soy milk and planned out the story. The action would take place on the day of the wedding. It would be a race against the clock scenario. The protagonist would have 24 hours to get over her ex-boyfriend. This struck me as an elegant conceit, and also an efficient one. If I woke up on the day of the wedding and wasn't yet over Shane, I wouldn't have to sweat. Thanks to the class, I'd have a 24-hour cure.
第二天早晨，在“紫花苜蓿”轮班期间，我喝着一大杯加豆奶的热茶，规划着故事。故事发生在婚礼当天。这将是一个与时间赛跑的场景。主角有24小时来忘掉前男友。这对我来说是一个优雅的构思，也是一个高效的。如果我在婚礼当天醒来还没有忘掉肖恩，我也不用冒汗。多亏了这门课，我会有24小时的治愈良方。
That evening, I sat at the computer. "On the day of the wedding, I worked a double shift," I wrote. "I punched in prices off cans of tuna and pints of Ben and Jerry's, weighed bags of peaches and by-the-pound salads from the salad bar, scooped change out of my drawer and counted it into customers' hands."
那天晚上，我坐在电脑前。“婚礼当天，我上了双班，”我写道。“我往外打着金枪鱼罐头和品脱装Ben and Jerry冰淇淋的价格，称着桃子和沙拉吧里按磅卖的沙拉，从抽屉里捞出零钱数到顾客的手里。”
I sat back and considered my opening. This was the right idea, but I wanted to change it slightly. I didn't want all the details to be exactly, exactly like my life.
我坐回去，审视我的开场白。这是个好主意，但我想要稍微改动一下。我不想让所有细节都和我生活中的完全、完全一样。
I copied the old version into a new document and began again. "On the day of the wedding, I worked a double shift. In 14 hours, I made 39 goat cheese and bagel sandwiches, wrapped 106 lunch boats in tight Saran wrap, and sliced through 16 different 10-inch cakes on the course of waiting on at least 357 customers. I was counting to keep my mind off of some other things."
我把旧版本复制到一个新文档里，重新开始。“婚礼当天，我上了双班。在14个小时里，我做了39个山羊奶酪贝果三明治，把106个午餐盒用紧密的保鲜膜包好，并切开了16个不同的10英寸蛋糕，在此期间至少接待了357位顾客。我是在计数以让自己不去想别的事情。”
I sat back. There, I thought, satisfied. As long as I switch myself from the front end to the deli department, nobody will know this is me. I called the story "Waiting." Like the girl behind the deli counter, I would be stationed in the classroom, waiting to be delivered a satisfying end.
我坐回去。在那里，我想，很满意。只要我把自己从前台调到熟食部，没人会知道这是我。我把故事命名为《等待》。就像那个熟食柜台后的女孩一样，我会驻扎在教室里，等待着一个令人满意的结局。
That evening I pedaled to class at race-day speed, full of anticipation. The class was a mix of undergrads and people a few years out of school, like a guy who rode the free trolley from coffeehouse to coffeehouse all day and an aerobics instructor with tan, very shiny legs. Then there was our teacher, George.
那天晚上，我以赛车速度骑车去上课，充满期待。班上有本科生，也有毕业几年的人，比如一个整天骑着免费电车穿梭在咖啡馆之间的人，还有一位腿部晒得很黑、非常有光泽的健美操教练。还有我们的老师，乔治。
"Let's start with 'Waiting,'" George said, as we sat down in class. This was it. I readied myself for the wise and luminous insights of my classmates.
“我们从《等待》开始，”乔治坐下时说。就是这样。我准备好迎接同学们睿智而明亮的见解了。
"OK. Just starting with the first paragraph," said the aerobics instructor, "I highly doubt someone would count everything like that."
“好的。刚从第一段开始，”健美操教练说，“我非常怀疑有人会那样数每一件事。”
"Yeah, but the girl. What's her name?" a red-headed Southerner jumped in. "Katie?" He looked around the room for confirmation. "She says in the very next sentence, 'I was counting to keep my mind off of some other things.' It's not like she does it every day."
“是的，但那个女孩。她叫什么名字？”一个红头发的南方人插嘴道。“凯蒂？”他环顾房间寻求确认。“她在下一句就说了，‘我是在计数以让自己不去想别的事情。’这又不是说她每天都那样做。”
"I guess I just don't think it's very realistic that somebody could remember all that in their head," the aerobics instructor said.
“我猜我只是觉得有人能把这一切记在脑子里不太现实，”健美操教练说。
"Maybe she was writing it down as she went along," somebody suggested. There were nods. I returned the nod. I leaned over the paper and made my first note. "Counting," I wrote, followed by a question mark. Small potatoes, small potatoes, I thought. Bring it on. What else?
“也许她是边做边写下来的，”有人建议。大家点点头。我回敬地点点头。我俯身在纸上记下了我的第一条笔记。“计数，”我写道，后面跟着一个问号。小事，都是小事，我想。来吧。还有什么？
"I was wondering where she went off to college," someone said. "I mean, it's back East, but where?" Murmurs of agreement. "Where she went off to college," I dutifully wrote. This was not going according to plan. Come on. How should she should get over him?
“我在想她去哪儿上的大学，”有人说。“我的意思是，是在东部，但在哪儿？”大家低声附和。“她去哪儿上的大学，”我顺从地写下。这没按计划进行。来吧。她应该怎样才能忘掉他？
"Wait, wait, wait," said the aerobics instructor. "About the bride. Or actually the wife. I thought it was weird how Katie never even thought about the wife, you know? She never even wondered what she was like."
“等等，等等，等等，”健美操教练说。“关于新娘。或者实际上是妻子。我觉得凯蒂从来没想过那个妻子很奇怪，你知道吗？她甚至从来没好奇过她是什样的人。”
I had to hand it to the aerobics instructor. Sometimes she would come out with something really sharp. "Why didn't she think about the wife?" I wrote, with a big, filled-in arrow next to the note. Why didn't I ever think about Tina, I wondered.
我不得不佩服那位健美操教练。有时她会冒出一些非常尖锐的观点。“为什么她没想过妻子？”我写道，在笔记旁边画了一个大大的填充箭头。为什么我从来没想过蒂娜，我心想。
"I guess also I didn't really have a sense of Shane," someone added. "I mean, it says he's a teacher and stuff like that, but I mean more about why he got married so quick." "Why Shane got married so quick," I noted. I was starting to see that there might be a problem. The class had some of the same questions about the characters that I did.
“我想我还不太了解肖恩，”有人补充说。“我的意思是，文中说他是老师之类的，但我指的是关于他为什么结婚那么快。”“肖恩为什么结婚那么快，”我记下了。我开始看出可能存在一个问题。班上对人物的疑问和我的一样。
"Let's talk about Katie's feelings for Shane," the teacher said. OK. Now we're getting somewhere, I thought.
“让我们谈谈凯蒂对肖恩的感情，”老师说。好的。现在我们说到点子上了，我想。
"There was this one part that I thought was pretty telling," said one of the older students, "where she says-- on page three, midway down the page." There was the sound of people flipping. "I don't think I loved Shane until he told me he was getting married."
“有一个部分我觉得很有说明性，”一位年长的学生说，“在第三页，页面中间偏下。”有翻书的声音。“在那之前我都不认为我爱肖恩，直到他告诉我他要结婚了。”
"Exactly," George nodded. "But I think it's getting buried in there. You might want to make it bigger," he said, addressing me directly, "or earlier.
“完全正确，”乔治点头。“但我认为它被埋在里面了。你可能想把它写得更大一点，”他直接对我说道，“或者更早点写出来。”
"But you wouldn't want to make that too much the point," someone said, "because obviously she was having a really hard time getting over him. I mean, she did feel something for him."
“但你不会想让它成为重点，”有人说，“因为很明显她忘掉他很困难。我的意思是，她对他确实有感觉。”
"Well, I think that's an interesting question," George said, tipping back in his chair. "What are Katie's true feelings? Is this is a story about social status, or is this a story about true love?" I didn't like the way the question was framed.
“好吧，我认为这是一个有趣的问题，”乔治说着，向后靠在椅子上。“凯蒂对他的真实感情是什么？这是一个关于社会地位的故事，还是一个关于真爱的故事？”我不喜欢这个问题被构建的方式。
"Social," the aerobics instructor said. "Definitely social. It seemed like she liked having an older boyfriend." Where was this in my story? But everyone was nodding. Encouraged, the aerobics instructor added, "I mean, if they'd been in love, it would have clicked when they were still together."
“社会地位，”健美操教练说。“肯定是社会地位。似乎她喜欢有一个大她很多的男朋友。”这在我的故事里有提到吗？但每个人都在点头。受到鼓励，健美操教练补充道，“我的意思是，如果他们相爱的话，当他们还在交往时就应该有感觉了。”
No! I felt everything slump inside me. As everyone bobbed their heads in agreement, that Shane and I hadn't been in love, I looked very intently at my paper. "Why didn't anything click?" I wrote. Then I couldn't write the rest of it, so I just made a long dash.
不！我觉得我内心的一切都塌陷了。当每个人都点头赞同我和肖恩没有相爱时，我非常专注地看着我的纸。“为什么没感觉？”我写道。然后我写不下去了，所以只画了一条长长的虚线。
"Maybe she's going through something more than just Shane," somebody suggested. I perked up a little. This was definitely possible. "But there's not enough in here to give us a sense of what that other thing she's going through might be," said George. "We don't know much about Katie. She went off to college. She enjoys mountain biking. But aside from that, who is she?"
“也许她经历的不仅仅是肖恩的事，”有人建议。我振作了一点。这绝对有可能。“但文中没有足够的内容让我们感知她经历的另一件事可能是什么，”乔治说。“我们对凯蒂了解不多。她去上大学。她喜欢骑山地车。但除此以外，她是谁？”
She's me, I thought. Look over here! Blonde hair, green skirt, far corner.
她就是我，我想。看这边！金发，绿裙子，远角。
The class was silent. Then George turned his entire body and looked me straight in the eye. Oh God, I thought. They know.
教室里一片沉默。然后乔治转过身，直视我的眼睛。哦，上帝，我想。他们知道了。
"Susan, you might need to do a little pre-writing about Katie. Get a sense of who she is. Figure her out a little more." Yes. I nodded vigorously, as if I, too, was hoping to unlock the mysteries of this girl I'd created.
“苏珊，你可能需要做一点关于凯蒂的前期写作。了解她是什么样的人。多弄清楚她一点。”是的。我用力点头，好像我也在希望能解开这个我创造出的女孩的谜团。
"OK. Well, we should really move on to the next one," said George. "Susan, I guess my final comment would be that the story needs an end. But it develops well. Nice job," he said.
“好的。好吧，我们真的应该进入下一个了，”乔治说。“苏珊，我想我最后的评论是故事需要一个结局。但它发展得不错。干得好，”他说。
I sat there blankly. The story needs an end? I thought. No duh, it needs an end. We are gathered together today to figure out the end. The story needing an end is the whole reason we are here. And now we just started talking about some other person's work.
我茫然地坐在那里。故事需要一个结局？我心想。这不用你说，它需要一个结局。我们今天聚在一起就是为了找出结局。故事需要结局是我们在这里的全部原因。而现在我们刚开始谈论其他人的作品。
I sat very still and looked around the bright room, all of us at the desks in a big circle. Nothing had happened. I was still the same. Except for now I'd tried this, and it seemed like I had no more chances.
我静静地坐着，环顾明亮的教室，我们所有人都坐在大圆圈的桌子旁。什么也没发生。我还是老样子。只是现在我试过这个了，似乎我没机会了。
I rode my bike home slowly. It made me feel lonely, thinking of the way they'd talked about my life. It was so in general. None of them knew that they were talking about a real girl in the world.
我缓慢地骑车回家。想到他们谈论我生活的方式，我感到孤独。那太笼统了。他们中没人知道他们在谈论现实世界里的一个真实女孩。
Then, as the days went by, I felt better. The class had acted like my story wasn't so unusual. Just some old thing with an ex-boyfriend. It made the whole thing feel smaller, like less of an emergency. Dozens of girls now riding their mountain bikes through these very foothills had dated boys and been hurt. It was something that people had heard of, something that happened all the time. It was a known thing that made people sad. Now I rode my bike along Arapahoe Road at the speed of a regular girl, wearing regular clothes, like shorts, and pointing my bike light in the regular direction, straight ahead.
然后，随着日子一天天过去，我感觉好多了。课堂表现得好像我的故事并不罕见。只是关于前男友的一件旧事。这让整件事感觉变小了，不再是那么紧急的危机。现在成百上千骑着山地车穿过这些丘陵的女孩都和男孩约会过并受过伤。这是人们听说过的事情，是一直在发生的事情。这是一件让人难过但众所周知的事情。现在我骑着车沿着阿拉帕霍路，保持普通女孩的速度，穿着普通的衣服，比如短裤，把自行车灯指向正常方向，直视前方。
For a while I still thought about Shane, and then suddenly, I didn't think about him at all. Except on every birthday, when I would think, I'm still not as old as he was. And then I was 23, and that was it. I didn't think about him anymore.
有一段时间我还在想肖恩，然后突然间，我一点也不想他了。除了在每个生日，我都会想，我还没他当年那么老。然后我23岁了，就是这样。我不再想他了。
Susan Burton from New York.
来自纽约的苏珊·伯顿。
Well you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, bestselling books, even the New York Times, all at audible.com.
嗯，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I only agreed to host This American Life because he promised me years ago--
WBEZ管理监督托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）。我同意主持《美国生活》只是因为他几年前向我保证——
Brian Dennehy is really interested in being in it, and so is Rebecca De Mornay.
布莱恩·丹内利真的很有兴趣参与其中，丽贝卡·德·莫妮也一样。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。